I have 24 hours and they're mine
this 24 hours belongs to me right and
whatever I'm doing this 24 hours will
determine where I'll be tomorrow and the
next day I think that's what people need
to focus on like get off of this I want
to make six figures I want to try this
car I want to live in this out I think
what people should be focusing on is I
have 24 hours like Oprah only has 24
Bill Gates only has 24 like Warren
Buffett only has 24 hours and in that 24
hour period
I can either break my life or make my
life and I think what should be on the
priority list is going to bed so you can
wake up the next day and you can grind
it out and I'm just a dude that believes
you reap what you sow so if you're
grinding or money grind it on Tuesday
grind it on Wednesday if you're grinding
six seven days a week for four span of
five or six years something's got to
come out of it we will spend more time
on what's my goal you know and meaning
what do I need to accomplish in this day
to live this lifestyle and you go after
it then I think I think more than you
will be successful education is the
great equalizer so no matter where you
are if you feel like you started at the
bottom and you're like man I'm at the
bottom
Eric and I want to live life like
everybody else I want to fly first-class
like I want to see the world you know I
don't want any limitations and I had to
realize for myself being a high school
dropout like you can't use that excuse
forever where I was born and where I was
raised
you can't use that forever and so to me
you liberate yourself it's not optional
the more you read the more liberated you
are and the more you are educated to me
the more you can experience a life like
the people that you're probably looking
at and saying I wish I could live like
that person you just watch too amazing
clip some Eric Thomas take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]